noch ist kein corona impfstoff in europa
zugelassen
er aber hat schon einen bekommen der von
dem deutschen unternehmen biontech
entwickelt wurde
denn hier ins kuntzl hat an einer
impfstoff studie teilgenommen als
proband wie war das als sie die erste
spritze bekommen haben mit einem neuen
impfstoff der noch gar nicht zugelassen
ist
also ich war sehr aufgeregt ja gerade
das umfeld wenn dann zwei schwestern
verein stehen mit voller
schutzausrüstung die spritze in der hand
und da gehen schon zum paar gedanken
durch den kopf kann jetzt was passieren
wie kamen sie auf die idee bei einer
ernsthaft studiert zu machen
meine erste intention war ein bisschen
geld nebenbei zu verdienen habe nicht
dann beworben bei einer klinik in
mannheim die probanden gesucht haben da
ist mir dann mit erklärt wurden dass sie
eine studie machen gerade über komik 19
also es war reiner zufall dass es dann
ein corona impfstoff war es war absolut
zu völkern jens kunst gehörte mit zu den
ersten menschen in deutschland an denen
der impfstoff getestet wurde
nicht jeder ist bereit dazu
kunze erhält wenn er bis zum ende
durchhält eine aufwandsentschädigung von
1770 euro
meine freunde waren zweigeteilt der eine
teil sagt gut dass das mitmachst
vielleicht bringt es ja was und man
hilft damit der andere teil war dann
eher so skeptisch das ist ja schon
gefährlich und was tust du dein körper
an
noch sind nicht alle studien
abgeschlossen
die entwicklung von impfstoffen ist
aufwändig und dauert in der regel
mehrere jahre
nicht so in zeiten dieser pandemie
impfstoffe müssen in drei phasen am
menschen getestet werden
schon elf corona impfstoffe haben die
dritte phase erreicht mit mehreren
tausend probanden und das in nur wenigen
monaten
einer davon kommt aus mainz die ganze
welt blickt deshalb auf die stadt am
rhein und auf piontek
denn das unternehmen hat einen der
vielversprechendsten kandidaten weltweit
entwickelt die dritte studienphase ist
beinahe abgeschlossen und es hat sogar
schon der zulassungsprozess bei der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur ema
begonnen
obwohl die zulassung aber noch aussteht
ist die produktion schon angelaufen
in zusammenarbeit mit dem amerikanischen
pharmakonzern pfizer
wir möchten zusammen mit unserem partner
phase in 20.20 bis zu 100 millionen
dosen impfstoff bereit stellen und für
20 jahren 20 haben uns vorgenommen bis
zu 1,3 milliarden impfstoff herzustellen
schon jetzt steht fest wer die ersten
dosen bekommt denn bier und tec hat
schon liefervereinbarungen mit mehreren
staaten abgeschlossen
etwa mit den usa großbritannien und mit
der eu
das unternehmen ist darüber hinaus noch
mit 30 weiteren ländern in gesprächen
unter den staaten ist ein wettstreit um
corona impfstoffe ausgebrochen
vor allem führende industrienationen
haben schon lieferverträge mit
herstellern abgeschlossen
allen voran die usa und großbritannien
auch die eu hat sich schon mehrere
hundert millionen dosen gesichert
doch vom corona virus betroffen sind
nicht nur wohlhabendere starten
das virus verbreitet sich auch in
ärmeren ländern rasant etwa in indien
indien steht weltweit auf platz 2 der
länder mit den meisten nachgewiesenen
infektionen in den großen städten wie
mumbai leben tausende menschen in slums
dr stoppten kalon leitet die korona
einsätze von ärzte ohne grenzen in
indien
auch er hofft dass es bald einen
impfstoff gibt um die pandemie effektiv
zu stoppen brauchen wir dringend einen
impfstoff vor allem in einem land wie
indien wird sich das corona virus ohne
impfstoff auch weiterhin stark in der
bevölkerung verbreiten und einen hohen
tribut fordern ohne impfstoff können die
ärzte den kampf gegen korona hier kaum
gewinnen
vor allem für die menschen in den slums
ist die situation extrem schwer weil die
bevölkerungsdichte hier sehr hoch ist
[Musik]
familien von fünf bis sechs personen
leben in nur einem einzigen raum enge
wohn und lebensverhältnisse nicht der
einzige grund warum abstand halten hier
kaum möglich ist in den slums in denen
wir zum beispiel in mumbai arbeiten wir
nun die menschen das risiko sich raus zu
gehen obwohl sie sich den virus
aussetzen weil sie geld verdienen muss
wenn sie nicht rausgehen bedeutet das
für ihre familien dass sie hungern
müssen ein shutdown wie in europäischen
ländern das ist hier nur schwer
durchsetzbar
doch die lebensbedingungen sind nicht
das einzige problem
viele slumbewohner sind analphabeten
können nicht lesen
auf der straße oder auch zu hause
versucht die ärzteorganisation möglichst
viele menschen zu erreichen und über das
virus aufzuklären
der kampf gegen korona ist in ländern
wie indien noch schwieriger als in
wohlhabenden staaten
doch gerade ärmere länder können es sich
nicht leisten millionen dosen an
impfstoffen für ihre bevölkerung zu
kaufen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation die whu
warnt vor dem wettstreit der reichen
staaten um corona impfstoffe dr blues
award leitet das internationale corona
programm auch für wohlhabende staaten
ist es besser wenn alle länder impfstoff
bekommen
nur so lassen sich die globalen risiken
durch kugeln 19 reduziert
die weltwirtschaft ist so stark
ineinander verflochten
wenn nur ein paar wenige länder
impfstoff bekommen werden wir weiter mit
den globalen problemen kämpfen bei
internationaler mobilität und beim
welthandel damit länder unabhängig von
ihrem wohlstand zugang zu impfstoffen
erhalten wurde unter dem dach der whu
eine internationale initiative ins leben
gerufen kovacs die idee
die staaten kaufen über kovacs gemeinsam
impfstoffe ein
die verteilung erfolgt unter
federführung der initiative der vorteil
besserer zugang zu impfstoffen für alle
zu günstigeren preisen
das soll die verteilung über kovacs
sichern zwei milliarden dosen will die
initiative zunächst bis ende 2021 zur
verfügung stellen
zwar haben sich bislang mehr als 180
länder weltweit kovacs angeschlossen
doch die millionen dosen die sich vor
allem wohlhabendere staaten im
alleingang sichern bleiben kovacs und
damit den ärmeren ländern vorenthalten
die eu will bei der verteilung über
kovacs nicht mitmachen
sie unterstützt die initiative aber
finanziell mit 500 millionen euro für
das sichern von dosen für die eigene
bevölkerung hingegen hat sie schon 2,7
milliarden euro vorgesehen
innerhalb der eu sollen die dosen dann
entsprechend der bevölkerungszahl der
einzelnen länder verteilt werden
die eu zahlt den herstellern schon jetzt
vorlaufkosten etwa für den aufbau von
produktionskapazitäten
[Musik]
drohen da nicht millionenverluste wenn
einer der kandidaten doch noch scheitern
sollte
das wird sich nicht vermeiden lassen
außerdem sehr großes glück dass auch
eine scheitert und dann in diesem teil
finanzielle verluste anfangen der korona
impfstoff wird zum spielball der staaten
in der internationalen politik
[Musik]
russland ist vorangeprescht und hat
seinen impfstoff sputnik in der
bevölkerung eingesetzt
ohne den abschluss aller studien
abzuwarten russland will sputnik auch in
andere länder liefern
auch china entwickelt eigene impfstoffe
die chinesische regierung hat etwas
staaten in afrika und südamerika dosen
in aussicht gestellt heute sind
impfstoffe kollektive welt güter wer sie
beherrscht denn wer über sie verfügen
kann und wer sie auch verteilen kann
er beherrscht internationale politik ein
stück wald und insofern versteht china
und russland dieses spielen im moment
sehr geschickt in dem es quasi allianzen
geschmiedet
insofern nimmt dir zurück auf einem
geopolitischen schlachtfeld dh die
machtpolitischen gewichte werden sich in
dieser frage der impfstoffentwicklung
neu sortieren das lied gewinner und
verlierer geben das heißt die
zweiteilung der welt wird sich
verstärken indem ich diese impfstoff
frage das rennen um den impfstoff ist
bereits in vollem gange
für viele staaten sind die preise die
hersteller aktuell verlangen aber
unerschwinglich so scheint es
grund für hohe preise unter anderem
forschung und entwicklung verschlingen
milliarden aufwendig sind auch die
studien an probanden für jens kunze
standen noch mehrere untersuchungen an
nach der ersten spritze mit dem neuen
impfstoff wahrscheinlich schon aufwendig
also ich war ja eine nacht auch
stationär dort da war stand unter
beobachtung nachdem ich die erste
spritze bekommen habe und dann hatte ich
noch mal wöchentlich nach sowie termine
es wird der ekg gemacht fieber gemessen
und blutdruck gemessen
die eigentlich die stelle wird beurteilt
also es wurden schon sehr viele
untersuchung noch danach gemacht wie
während der ganzen zeit hatte ich
eigentlich keine angst nein aufgeregt
war man aber angst hatte ich nicht
jens kunze ist nur einer von mehreren
10.000 biontech probanden damit sich die
hohen investitionen in forschung und
entwicklung von impfstoffen für
pharmaunternehmen lohnen gibt es patente
sie schützen bis zu 20 jahre lang vor
günstigeren nachahmungen dank ihrer
patente können pharmaunternehmen aber
auch oft hohe preise verlangen
wie können sich patente auf corona
impfstoffe auswirken
das zentrallager von ärzte ohne grenzen
die organisation ist auf günstige preise
angewiesen denn sie finanziert
arzneimittel mit spenden
tausende pharmaprodukte lagern hier auch
impfstoffe von hier aus werden sie zu
einsätzen von ärzte ohne grenzen
weltweit geschickt
ich treffe marco alves wie kommen er und
seine kollegen an bezahlbare
arzneimittel rund 94 prozent der
medikamente die wir einsetzen bei der
behandlung von hiv/aids tuberkulose
malaria sind sogenannte generika
das sind qualitativ gleichwertige
nachahmerpräparate im grunde eigentlich
kopien von originalprodukten völlig
legale kopien die aber viel viel
günstiger sind und zwei drittel dieser
generika die wir einkaufen kommen aus
indien indien gilt weltweit als nummer
eins in der produktion von generika also
von nachahmungen ein grund ist das
indische patentrecht der aspekt der
öffentlichen gesundheit ist in indien
besonders wichtig dadurch hat man darauf
geachtet dass das patentrecht sehr sehr
strikt sehr rigoros darin ist bei der
patentvergabe eben genau darauf zu
achten ob ein präparat auch tatsächlich
ein patent bekommen sollte ob die
ausreichende erfindung höhe besteht je
weniger patente desto mehr günstige
generika könnten hergestellt werden
patentgeschützte arzneimittel seien
hingegen in der regel deutlich teurer
für kranke menschen könnte das zum
problem werden
denn in der korona pandemie ist nicht
mehr nur eine patientengruppe betroffen
sondern die ganze weltbevölkerung
wenn wir in eine situation kommen dass
patente wesentliche hürden dafür
darstellen dass nicht ausreichend mengen
produziert werden oder nicht ausreichend
bezahlt zur verfügung gestellt werden da
müssen regierungen weltweit dringend
handeln impfstoffhersteller müssen bei
der entwicklung und produktion oft auch
basis technologien einsetzen die andere
unternehmen entwickelt haben wie zum
beispiel beim impfstoff des
us-unternehmens moderner der weltweit zu
den vielversprechendsten kandidaten
gehört
das unternehmen hat einen neuartigen gen
basierten impfstoff entwickelt um den in
die zellen zu transportieren braucht es
ein verfahren dass ein anderes
unternehmen entwickelt hat und das hält
dafür ein patent in solchen fällen sind
impfstoffhersteller darauf angewiesen
dass ihnen der patentinhaber eine lizenz
erteilt sonst dürfen sie das produkt
nicht auf den markt bringen
für diese lizenzen müssen
impfstoffhersteller zahlen der
patentinhaber geht also nicht leer aus
verweigern unternehmen jedoch solche
lizenzen können starten im sinne des
gemeinwohls eingreifen da kann es
durchaus sinnvoll sein wenn unternehmen
nicht freiwillig lizenzen vergeben auch
zwangs lizenzen anzudrohen solche zwangs
lizenzen sind aber an höhere an hohe
rechtliche hürden geknüpft besser und
effektiver wäre es daher wenn sich
unternehmen bei basistechnologien
freiwillig auf lizenzen und die kosten
dafür einigen moderne hat angekündigt
seine eigenen patentrechte im
zusammenhang mit der pandemie nicht
durchzusetzen
es ist zunächst mal zu begrüßen weil es
dazu führen wird dass jedenfalls im
hinblick auf die patente von moderner
andere unternehmen forscher keine sorgen
haben müssen dass die patentansprüchen
ausgesetzt sind
es wäre wünschenswert dass mehr
unternehmen sich idealerweise mit
rechtsverbindliche erklärungen dazu
bereit erklären ihre patente nicht
durchzusetzen während der pandemie wie
wirken sich patente auf die gewinne der
impfstoffhersteller aus den unternehmen
die den wettlauf um einen corona
impfstoff gewinnen winken milliarden
profitieren können auch ihre aktionäre
schon bevor ein impfstoff überhaupt auf
den markt gekommen ist sind die kurse in
den vergangenen monaten teils stark
gestiegen etwa wenn die unternehmen
fortschritte in studien verkündet haben
oder liefervereinbarungen mit starten
der erfolgs anreiz ist es die
aktienkurse steigen
das ist ein erfolgs anreiz der gesetzt
wird den aktienkurs zu steigern weil
genau diese aktienkurs natürlich auch
die anleger im kopf haben und sie
profitieren beide von steigenden
aktienkursen
unternehmen manager aktionäre sie alle
profitieren von corona impfstoffen und
je höher der preis pro dosis desto höher
auch die gewinne gewinninteressen und
globale gesundheit in der korona
pandemie könnte das zu konflikten führen
suri moon ist expertin für globale
gesundheitspolitik sie entwickelt
modelle für faire pharmapreise
unternehmen sollen dabei durchaus
gewinne machen können aber ein preis ist
unfair wenn er dem unternehmen faire
gewinne bringt aber wenn
gesundheitssysteme ihn nicht bezahlen
können letztendlich haben dann viele
menschen keinen zugang zu wichtigen
arzneimitteln weil ihre regierungen oder
krankenversicherungen diesen preis nicht
bezahlen können
auch die kosten für forschung und
entwicklung sollen pharmafirmen
einspielen können
doch das geld dafür kommt nicht nur von
den unternehmen selbst
laut einer studie werden 100 prozent der
arzneimittel mit forschungsförderung
entwickelt denn alle arzneimittel bauen
auf forschungsergebnissen auf die über
einen längeren zeitraum gewonnen werden
wissenschaft wächst wie eine steinmauer
ist jeder wissenschaftler jedes labor
jedes unternehmen führt einen stein
hinzu also entsteht das fundament auf
dem arzneimittel produziert werden
die öffentliche hand ist der
hauptförderer dieses wunder -
in der korona pandemie investieren
regierungen milliarden in die
entwicklung eines impfstoffs ich halte
es für angemessen dass wir im gegenzug
angemessene preise bekommen
die öffentliche förderung und forschung
und entwicklung sollte zudem absolut
transparent sein denn es ist das geld
der steuerzahler
und sie sollten wissen wofür ihr geld
ausgegeben wird und ihre regierung zur
rechenschaft ziehen können
auch die eu fördert die
impfstoffentwicklung mit mehreren
millionen euro heißt dass die impfstoffe
werden dadurch auch günstiger wie sich
das dann genau in heller und pfennig
oder in euro und cent niederschlägt kann
ich ihnen nicht sagen wieviel kostet
jeweils eine dosis und gibt es da große
preisunterschiede
dazu können wir noch keine zahlen warum
gibt die eu diese informationen nicht
preis haben die steuerzahler die eu
bürger nicht ein recht auf transparenz
die steuerzahler haben absolut ein recht
auf transparenz ist es aber auch in
deren interesse dass die transparenz
nicht zu einem zeitpunkt stattfindet wo
es die preise noch erhöhen könnte
die eu hat also sorge dass die impfstoff
hersteller die preise im zuge der
verhandlungen in die höhe treiben
denn die nachfrage ist hoch im
wettstreit der staaten um impfstoffe
sind die impfstoffhersteller da nicht in
einer deutlich komfortableren
verhandlungsposition was die preise
betrifft sicherlich gibt es eine große
nachfrage und wie das so ist auf märkten
bestimmt dass auch den preis laut jaguar
jahren wird die eu die preise und wie
sie zustande kommen irgendwann
veröffentlichen
doch das eu parlament fordert schon
jetzt mehr transparenz und einsicht in
die verträge auch die bundesregierung
fördert die impfstoffentwicklung mit
mehreren hundert millionen euro
auf die frage wie sich das auf die
preise auswirkt antwortet sie sie können
aus rechtlichen gründen keine vorgaben
zu solchen konditionen machen
sicher ist nur für corona impfstoffe
werden viele millionen an steuergeldern
ausgegeben
noch ist unklar wie lange die impfstoffe
schützen
bei probanden kunze sollen schon
antikörper gegen das corona virus
festgestellt worden seien so gut
vertragen
denn auch stolz drauf dass es mit
gemacht hat würde das auf jeden fall
auch noch mal wieder machen
ich bin stolz darauf dass ich mich
wurden beitrag für die forschung
geleistet habe ich muss mich bei den
antiken regeln halten man nicht weiß wie
lang die antike behalten die ich
gebildet habe und deswegen setze ich
weiterhin meine maske auf
behörden und politik arbeiten bereits an
konzepten für die impfung in deutschland
medizinisches personal und risikogruppen
wie ältere menschen sollen die ersten
sein
doch bis es genug dosen für alle gibt
das wird auch in deutschland noch monate
dauern
es reicht aber nicht wenn nur reiche
staaten ihre bevölkerung impfen
die gesamte weltbevölkerung muss zugang
zu corona impfstoffen erhalten durch
eine gerechte verteilung und faire
preise dafür muss die
staatengemeinschaft sorgen sonst wird
sie den kampf gegen das virus nicht
gewinnen
[Musik]